[Music]  well Superbowl this week of course ma'am  millions of Americans will be having  Super Bowl parties but with the economy  in rough shape most people are on a very  tight budget this year so here with some  money saving Super Bowl party tips is  our prop master bill tall bill take an  avocado smash it with the book boom  guacamole here's bill with another tip  bill take a Big Mac shovel in the  blender boom Super Bowl chili here's  another one  take a bowl of milk toss in a seashell  boom New England clam chowder and  another one  organize a Super Bowl pool stuff the  money in a gym bag boom start a new life  and this one take your regular TV hold  it up to your face boom big screen TV  [Music]  there we go  I can't anymore  I just can't go on alright